We did it. Yep.
You done it.
So many people have been raving about these
and saying that they're good, so,
uh, I'm terrified.
I actually don't know what they look like.
I just got a flavor of each.
Apparently, they rotate flavors every week. Okay,
this is what we're working with.
I'm actually really scared.
Why am I sweating right now?
I don't know. I'm not too sure what any of these flavors are.
I know we have, actually. Remember,
I think this is something with peanut butter.
This is the classic chocolate chip one.
Then I think this is the chocolate chip oat one.
Oh, that sounds good.
Sunday brownie. I think pumpkin something.
Ooh, pumpkin is haunting us.
Pumpkin something.
And then this is the one I'm actually the least afraid of,
which is Oreo. Okay,
what do we start with? The brownie. Cause it looks.
I mean, it could be worse, actually.
What do you rate it? Uh,
it's a. It's literally a brownie to me,
so I don't know. I rate it brownie.
So this is the pumpkin one.
I like that. That's nice.
Hmm.
Reminds me of my childhood for some reason.
The frosting is so good. Holy crap.
Oh, it is real good.
What do you rate that? 1 7.
That's pretty high for you.
Let's try this Oreo one. Why are you making that face?
This one's gonna be the best one.
This is the Oreo one.
But you don't like either.
That one wasn't good.
Okay, let's try this one.
I. Okay.
I don't wanna try the peanut butter one.
You have to. I don't like peanut butter at all.
Hmm.
What do you rate that one?
27. 27. I give it a two.
It's like another butter. I don't know what that is.
Here. For the frosting,
honestly. Just a classic chocolate chip. Cheers.
Very classic.
You make better cookies.
Great thought. A6.
A6, too, right?
Yeah, I think oatmeal chocolate chip.
I'm not even trying these anymore. I've given up.
A 6, too.
I give that a 6. I mean,
the chocolate chip ones are pretty tied.
Which one was your favorite overall?
The peanut butter. Really?
All the way to me, weirdly enough.
Pumpkin one.
Really good. Hey,
what do you give this overall?
Like, is this worth the hype?
I give this overall experience a 6 or a 7?
Like, would you pay 32 bucks for this again?
Oh, because I wouldn't get three out of the six you got.
Peanut butter one was very good.
Very delicious, very nutritious.
Very amazing. Very awesome.
Very good. Lovely.
Good job. Wow,
you're so animated. Okay,
good job. I need to go sleep. Bye.